[Music]
okay so this puck is basicly is not too
loud okay now okay okay
this talk is basically inspired by
people using databases in the terms that
we picking them into in the same way we
pick lanch if we go to a lunch with our
friends basically we pick that we pick
those dishes that we ate yesterday or
normally with or we pick those that most
of the people are getting and this this
is basically the worst way to pick
databases since in most cases this is
the most expensive most complex and the
element element in a system and also the
element that has the biggest
significance in terms of how how they
will look like in terms of performance
and now okay okay in terms of
performance and so on so yeah basically
this yeah so Who am I to basically judge
you and your preferences in databases
I'm currently the read lead of R&D in
kavadis and we are hiring so come on I'm
running cookies it's a side project that
you can it's probably okay and running
I'm I'm tweeting at my pizza so if you
have any hate or something like this
either you like it or you don't like it
you don't like this talk go ahead and
the last I'm blogging curtain is out of
range and quite often Lee who are
writing about databases so yeah so
basically if we want to talk about
databases so we should first define what
is a database and we can go to a to the
Wikipedia and look at the definition but
this is kind of boring let's do it
in an epic kind of different way let's
define some must-haves that a system
will have to call it call today the
database and let's define some should
have so all must-haves first we should
store data in persistent way sounds kind
of all kind of obvious yeah
next we should be able to retrieve the
data in a in a percent way so if we do
two selects
after each other we should get basically
the same amount of a time if there
wasn't any data change and insert it
should be the same and the last one we
should be able to delete data so because
after a year it would be nice if our
database wouldn't have cup of petabytes
of unused data and should have we should
be able to query later now what's the
difference between getting the data and
querying the data getting the data is
basically by ID locking cap key value
stores and querying is by any random and
any random field so yeah it's quite nice
to do it next updating data basically
updating can be done using a deal and an
insert but if we are using an irrational
databases or auto-generated keys we are
in a kind of trouble because this this
element wouldn't be the same so in this
case I'm saying about partial partial
updates or the whole code key updates
and next transactions and this is the
part where people say oh what that
applies with our transactions actually
very small percentage of databases
actually have transactions I'm not
talking about autonomously I'm not
talking about transactions so doing
multiple operations as one basically if
any of them fails the whole operation
fails and basically putting define what
what do we do next okay so what's this
simple database the lowest level you can
get any ideas come on come on come on
you know the answer so this doesn't
count okay yeah exactly a file basically
why because of a file is the building
block of anything you can build upon any
database any system we eventually write
to a file so let's go and look at the
files from the must-haves we file is the
definition of actually storing data in a
persistent way yeah because it's file
and we have we have the ability to
retrieve data basically it's a file so
yeah and from the should haves we have
the ability query data and not only by
the name we can we can also do it by
path in most systems have built-in
functions to query by text in so if if
it's a text file it's quite easy in
quite efficient we can update the public
files and not only
we can do partial updates so we say
right this this data from this this bite
this bite so it's quite awesome and not
not all by databases habit and last we
have transactionality productions and
even more awesome or less awesome a
files actually support this video
transactions so we can actually say
write this to the database this to
another database and this file if any
other of those three operations failed
rollback everything that's said if any
of you had any to do with this with the
transactions there's one to say we can
do it that doesn't mean we should do it
because it increased complexity time and
the number of errors you will get quite
significantly
okay so let's complicate things a bit
why because files are awesome but if you
have for example two machines getting to
the files we are a remote server all you
have multiple processes that kind of
doesn't work so we have to create an
interface to do it in a kind of
disability and do it remotely so what we
won't be complicated that much so let's
go to our a bit Kyle high-level let's go
to key value stores so basically we have
key and a value value is arbitrary that
doesn't care what it is it's a blob from
their side so basically it's quite
simple implementation in case of files
we can basically calculate the hash of
the full path and that's it so why do we
actually do it those it was ultra fast
they are the only faster database are
those embedded basically those databases
I wrote in the process but in this case
if an apple Redis is cognitum their
performance in nanoseconds internal so
it's quite fast next there are scalable
why because in most cases do this
databases operate in that kind of in a
multi master scenario so if you take for
example our relation at the basis of a
master slave database so this way
basically waits until the master fails
then it takes over in this scenario you
actually have all the devices all the
servers are currently running and that's
it so you are not wasting any
computing computing power that was
simple and why simplicity is quite
awesome in the debate because those
fingers are really complex become quite
easy like replication adding notes and
so on so on and this makes for example
running the mana production really
easier and leads to less errors so let's
take the fastest one memcached
this plantation would be in a kind of
way I'm comparing databases top three
top two databases from DB engines come
the ranking of mostly use databases and
grouping them by type of database so
let's look at the first one memcache
mostly used key value database first
let's look at the how are we connecting
to database we have tcp/ip so what this
gives up what this tells us which it
tells us that we will be really fast but
actually we won't be able to scale or to
get though to be more thoughtful to a
fault-tolerant why because if we would
have foreign participate the CPP is
basically we do one in one request and
come back if the server fails we can
easily redirect it to another server if
if we have tcp/ip we have a constant
connection so it will be quite hard to
route but it would be quite fast next
data first it's completely in in memory
database next basically everything is
stored binary so if we have this VIP we
are sending data binary and we are
storing it binary so it will be fast it
will be extremely fast but if we are
storing the time the inter in memory
what happens if we run out of run and
this is well other you Thomasson is the
last recently used item but if we have
four gigabytes of RAM dedicated for
memcached what will happen if we
examples have four gigabytes taken and
we send a 10 megabyte block marrakech
will take the least recently used block
and delete it then take another one
another one until it finds enough place
to store the key so it's a database but
it deletes data so it isn't it didnt
even fulfill the first item for story
a persistent way but people are using it
and it's acronym fast yeah it's a cute
as a feature so basically this opened
and it's not in a way of you have to
check out check box you have to add a
dealer and compile it in a way that you
have security so if you open your data
if you put it on production you can find
that your data is missing or either
worst it has been changed by someone not
a good feature next clustering so the
way how we do how we go above one server
and one database in this case we
actually have shown a HIPAA nothing
architecture why because this database
is basically a hash table in on remote
servers the client actually knows knows
where where he should send the data so
it's quite awesome it's very very very
simple idea but it's going very very
fast so why was it built for caching
data basically for mostly website and so
on so on but sometimes people are using
it as a as a database next let's go to
number three actually in the most used
databases that's read this and the
extension of the name actually tells us
tells us what it is it's a remote the
dictionary server so let's look at it
we're gonna have to see IP so we will be
fast we are still in data in a bit
complex complex way because it's still a
key value store but we have types why do
we have types basically for a simple
reason for planning bags because finding
bags because here we have proper class
drink so if we have conflicts it's if if
we had to operation of our to list
there will be no conflicts but if we are
putting all the list itself will have
conflicts so those list types though
those data types make it easier to
resolve conflicts that's all and
actually make it easier of course also
to store data from for the hyper lock
locks a data structure is really good at
storing very sparse probabilistic data
look into it on capira is really it's a
really good article and the world the
everything in Redis is a string that's a
very strange concept but where this is
building upon this concept really
awesome features
like string operations if you have a
developes string where this gives you
the operations for moe to replace in the
value add to value or do any string
operations in a remote server why is it
awesome because if your value is quite
big you're not sending it and if you're
doing those atomic operations that will
be fast you won't have conflicts so yeah
they built a really interesting feature
upon upon the basic basic concept that
they've decided on upon next it's
computing in memory Redis has ways to be
to store data on disks but there are two
actually there are two ways but none of
them gives the gives the want me to show
if someone basically takes the cable off
after the server you won't be up to date
because all those metas methods are a
synchronous the only way to actually for
readies to be persistent you have to
have battery supported ROM which is
quite expensive and it doesn't doesn't
make any sense to be cannot pick another
database clustering and in case of
clustering reduces its it's quite an
interesting architecture because it's
auto-discovery out to healing so if we
basically if you didn't know disappears
release will the cluster will take take
care of spreading data avenge spreading
data in this way that it's still okay if
you add a class or basically run a write
run our this server with the name of the
cluster and it out of discovers how to
spread the data across the cluster and
it's all so simple again next nope nope
I'm seeing no Reds also has no guarantee
of consistency that means that there was
a really tiny chance and it's really
quite good in the documentation that
Redis will give you unconstant data
those rights you did eventually will end
up in a bit different way it's a very
narrow chance but it will happen and
master/slave where this has a very
interesting way of spreading data
because as I said all of the data is by
the law servers are active but you can
we can actually do
to restructure master/slave on
replication so we are not sending data
that became the big of amount of data
over the network and we are more
intelligent in a way
so why was and it has transactions in a
proper proper transactions and we won't
see those for a long time and it has
pops of operations not that interesting
for data science but actually for
running on production it's quite good in
Sukhram invest why was it built for
speed
basically we are wasting we are not
having presidency but we are having
extremely extreme speed why basically
what's the data base why do we want to
want to go further and be complicated
anymore in this case if your value is a
50 megabyte object getting it every time
actually will be slow and it won't be
the device won't be slow your network
could be so your application will be
slow and so on someone and we actually
have values that are quite big so again
let's complicate things a bit but not
that much let's add a select operation
what's the select operation basically we
can say which values which columns we'll
choose so we basically narrowing data so
basically going from this it's a simple
simple keep I will key value your
presentation will go to this so we'll
split the value part again into into key
value pairs and this is what what it's
called basically a white stable
databases wipes are white white column
databases not confuse them with con
databases because they are completely
different idea but again why do we do it
there are fast there are not extremely
fast because they know more about your
data so there will be a bit slower there
can narrow the now the data that are we
are receiving from the server so we are
not using the network and if you are far
away that's a quite quite interesting
thing to look at
there are scalable we can still have
multi server architecture so we can we
are using all of our resources
they are simply Sh I would say so
running them on production is a bit more
trickier but still quite nice
and we have data types so we can
checkout it our data if it if it is in
the same type that we assume it is so a
bit more description we don't have to
have additional documentation about
what's in the values we see it in the
database and we have partial updates in
some really narrow net cases and we have
querying because we know actually what's
happening we know the types very very
simple querying so the first and the
most most popular database in this case
us is of course Cassandra and if we look
at the data we have compression and why
do you have compression in in Cassandra
in which cases so basically he is
actually built by AWS Amazon in the case
of implementing the shopping basket
what's the simplest way to implement a
shopping basket it's actually to have as
a columns the product and as values the
number of items you actually want to
have but if we were to do it in a
relation at the base we'll end up with
huge joints really really huge turns
over millions millions of elements or in
OP database and so on but if we do it
not white cone database we are we can
actually win storing we can actually
ignore the products products that have
no or 0 because actually the application
knows what what are the all possible
values so if we have really sparse data
data this beta base is really really
good because we are we are using only
the only the actual part that we need so
from a couple of millions items to for
max 10 basically that's it next querying
first cousin had had MapReduce then
introduced sequel sequel is basically
SQL with with only only the Select part
and very very simple we're part of
course we don't have joins no way
as for to us for clustering
this is where Cassandra actually shines
in and it's actually the main reason why
people choose it because it's fast
the architecture of Cassandra is
basically a wrinkled architecture so we
can quite easily add any knows the rink
and basically it it extends another
quite interesting thing with rink
architecture is basically we can have
consistency the costigan we can be told
by the application so if we have four
five no snoring we can say right this
data to one of the notes or we can write
it we can say it right it's up to all
five for the notes and wait for the
replication so if we want to be fast we
write it to basically one note if we
really have to have to really want to
have consistency we wait a bit longer
and write it to all the notes with
awesome and this gives us fault
tolerance and but it also gives us one
problem that it's the biggest problem
basically if you if you google Cassandra
problem it is the first item cassandra
isn't row consistent so we have weekly
have two operations on the same row
Cassandra will be and you have some kind
of touching the same column Cassandra
will pick we have to choose which which
data to choose actually because I will
pick and that's rude
the lexically biggest so it will sort
the values and pick the value and insert
so because it's actually atomic on
updating each column but update as we
see from the application basically from
this key update those columns no that's
not the way it works this gives us
actually the speed of Cassandra but it's
the number one problem in people running
Cassandra and it's a number of problems
when people are using a database and not
reading any basic documentation and then
they have really big problems and of
course this gives us that from the cap
theorem we are not choosing constancy we
actually available because it's really
fast and we almost always give us either
an answer
it's answer may not be consistent but
hey that's the data type of database
next and it's also of course built for
distribution now let's go to a complete
different scenario we have HBase and
actually it will demand from the Google
Talk apart because it's not there so a
database over over a tube so in this
case let's think about what are the main
main cases basically if we are talking
about Hadoop we are talking about huge
data sets
so that's awesome so and you will see
actually how those basic ideas evolve in
this application basically data it's row
consistent and the data is versioned and
it's of course pretty good for a nice
path data as any white community basis
so but let's get back to row consistency
a versioning how does actually eight
base work it actually rides rides the
document as a whole each time because
it's assumed that hey we are dealing
with dealing with gigabytes petabytes of
data so if I add a document that has ten
megabytes additionally that's not a big
of a deal
and I'm only reading from those those
documents that had the maximum version
and I'm cleaning those documents that
are not up-to-date basically whenever I
can this is why is this really awesome
because any kind of disk
basically maybe not SSDs but basically
the hosts hard drive that we are using
for really big amounts of data they are
really fast sort of writing but are
really really slow at seeking data so
basically writing bits here visitor and
so on and so on so if we are writing ten
megabytes it's really fast but if you
are working a couple of kilobytes in
different places it will take a lot of
time and we'll use the derive so yeah
that's it
because we are running on top of hat
atom on top of Hadoop this how does it
the database works and for querying we
have drilled also talked about I talked
about on the keynote and we have
extremely fast reads why because we are
built upon a reporting system but the
rights will be quite slower as for
clustering it's quite complex and get
basically running Hadoop edge observer a
place it's quite complex we have
zookeeper we don't have any
transactionality enough but of course we
have consistency because yeah if you if
we have a reporting system the
availability we can go down cup couple
of times but we really have to be
consistent and for what what was it
built of course for reporting and the
last not that well-known but quite it
quite an interesting view also a white
cone database run also also runs on on
top
Hadoop and but basically has one really
unique feature and remember that we are
talking about petabytes of data you can
give privileges to each column in sorry
to each cell in the database so let's
imagine what company needs has really
high security security security
management and has petabytes of data
someone any other is the NSA actually
the data and as I develop the world is a
database in-house and gave it to the
Apache foundation you can actually now
use it as normal up in any normal Apache
Apache finish net database of course for
what for security and again those are
free databases that are the same type
but we behave completely different now
they have completely different and usage
and so look at them and basically what's
the problem why are we going even
further in further because we have quite
fast database we can query and so on it
basically looks awesome because naming
of things is really complicated if we go
if we go to more complex types it gets
recommit so let's complicate things a
bit now that much but only a bit complex
data types large lists and nested
objects imagine modeling lists in a
white community database you'll actually
have the indexes so that that's quit
that gets quite complex after counting
governments and so on so on and metal
objects yeah you'll have a lot of dots
that's not nice
so let's look at the most popular object
at the base monk I've caused the most
used database in case of opera databases
and synchronizing ok data it stores data
in binary JSON and basically it has data
types which is quite nice but what's
actually the hardest part if we actually
wanted to implement at the audio
database was a hottest part it's
actually storing data types of variant
lengths
because if you have a if we have a file
no this structure we can actually do
quite simple things read from this by
two despite it will be our amount for
example but if we have a table that's
going quite quite complex because we we
don't know where this table table ends
so mogul just said you won't have any
variant length types the collections
have it has to they have to be the size
because you have to have to be told up
front and for querying we of course have
dot notation because we're talking about
every database we have where operations
and not only those not only those simple
simple operations but we have operations
from of whole dates because comparing
strings is quite easy but comparing
dates smaller bigger you actually have
to understand the type so yeah we have
it we have example we have explained
profiling we didn't have explained for
profiling in any other previous database
because there was no need and here we
get quite complex so we should be able
to explain why either to run in quite
slow and finally we are quite complexity
we don't have joints why because there
was completely separate type separate
types of documents basically clustering
starting with a single application what
does it mean as basically if we have ten
[ __ ] databases and you write to the
master the only way to read accurate
data is from the master the replicas
only have as replications so we can read
from them but there is no guarantee that
the data would be up-to-date sounds good
so so and why was it built for speed in
distribution it's really it's it's fast
it's distributed and that's all
constancy not much
next a ws then I want to be also quite
popular popular database and let's look
at the use case purple it's a SAS
product so basically you can't have it
on premise and you have to you have to
actually go to AWS and pick up slider
and actually tell the throughput data
you we don't have a schema
Roah can only have 64 kilobytes but
that's not much I would say there's 1
megabyte limit on the query and after it
data will be basically cut and we have
limited checks on data so basically we
can declare it but database when
returning home check it the data that's
being returned is with the proper type
for curing we have no secondary indexes
so it won't be fast of course we don't
have any complex queries no drawings
nothing nothing at all and it's price
and throughput and this actually gives
us the answer why do we have all of the
above because Dynamo is basically if you
wanted by the na mo you go and you see a
slider how many operations a second do
you want to have and basically as you
move the slider the price increases and
that's all and I guarantee that you will
have this fruit why why do we have this
restriction because it's running on a
Deborah's infrastructure if they want to
guaranteed the throughput they have to
have those limits it has to be it has to
be a really simple database is basically
a speed as a service that's all let's
make things a bit more a bit more
complex joins actually this Google is
always suggesting me that I meant not
join us but something different so why
do we actually let's complicate those
things why do we actually want to
complicate because connected in most
cases we we want to find the mean
between couple of collections we want to
have we want to see how this compares to
this and so on
so the connecting part is quite
important and one thing to note in here
we are not patent conference there are
wars between multiple languages which is
better faster more awesome or hip and so
on so on so on those were are those were
completely nothing compared to wars
between different types of databases you
will you will see Oracle fans destroying
SQL fans and the guys from MySQL saying
that those are the better priced way too
much most of them that let's put it
right here are not
in telling the truth or telling a very
limited scope of what they know about it
other babies really dig in to dig in the
documentation and see what is happening
and in here basically does anybody know
how long do we have relational databases
how old are they mmm very good about 45
something like this basically so we put
billions of dollars into those databases
so you would assume that they are more
or less the same they are not basically
let's look at ternopil versioning
versioning basically we have MVCC and
log based why is it important because
log base up databases are really better
at right heavy operations and VCC are
really better at right right
operations and the MVC will actually if
you see vamp all that the SQL server is
killing your disk disk using IMDB yes
this is exactly MVCC basically because
it has to persist those transactions on
disk yeah next memory tables because now
we have having half a terabyte in RAM
isn't is not that big of a deal sorry
what providers made it let's put this
data this data in in RAM storage and
let's do something with it and or
concept yeah let's do reporting on those
state tables ms set no let's do online
interaction processing so let's do no
more patient's let's make those table
wrong tables behave like normal tables
two completely different views and of
course my school said no that's too
expensive you wouldn't do it and that
and the other guy said no let's fall to
database and they made Mariano Mariano
DB which are Mariana which I of course
supports which is a column database next
as for scaling Oracle says that they
have rack I didn't use it the other one
basically have sharding completely
different different architectures for
colonists what accommodates is if you
have spurs data thumbs up all they tell
you that you are grouping upon and
basically you can treat them as a
basically dictionary so in the under
rows or you will only have the IDs
that in the house will be stored in a
separate dictionary this is really
really awesome for querying aggregating
data and as a service it yet
yeah let's remand it and Oracle said
nope it was actually full in those two
biggest ones but in MySQL you actually
will on alter will alter commit
transactions and the other engine will
say if you are doing transaction
attraction transactions that across
multiple tables then you don't have any
transactionality yeah this is the base
is for free remember this next city city
what's basically those this is the way
if you have a structure that is very
cold and you don't know its depth using
City you can basically have recursive
queries that will go all the way down
until you have the whole tree you have
it in Oracle and SQL Server but in MySQL
no so you will from doing one query you
will do multiple queries as as many as
many layers yeah and that's it so what's
your problem we have almost anything we
want currently reporting actually and
how how many of you have actually heard
that yeah we I want to have this report
by the end of the day yeah one person
okay so let's this time flip flip and
flip things a bit by 90 degrees for for
fast reporting for aggregation
compression and basically having fast
writes by the cost of of reads the other
way around we have two data until it is
quite in quite an interesting way into
the database they exist for forty that
forty three thirty years and to give you
a scale of scale of the episode we are
talking about the data in case of
Walmart one table has more than one 1
comma five petabytes of data one table
that's quite a lot of data yeah in case
of data you basically have column and
row so basically you are storing in case
of column storing here we have our
separate index and us also storing only
IDs so that's really fast for a good
aggregation and query
and you can also read the Jason but you
have really limits on some types of
values and it's a really simple database
in this case you have Anthony SQL
because those are because cause are
really a lot but if you want them you
don't have you don't have the ability
true so yeah don't count on features and
walls with Hadoop why because we are in
the world of reporting so it will work
on the other side we have Monty be it's
free so it's nice to nice to see as for
the data we have purely column column on
orientated data for querying we have SQL
support and we have database cracking so
the database is able to index the
elements as their us they are used so we
don't pay the pay the cost upfront and
writing always and we have keys support
cql support for that's for arrays we
have for some bomb support for sparse
data I think and the RDF is basically a
graph querying and we have support for
our Python and if you are if we are
looking for really big datasets look for
this database basically because from a
human genome the big hydron Collider yet
they are storing in the database and
most academic use it don't count on
documentation or phone support or any
and food this way but what seems to be
wrong with those way we covered all of
the Deb ESS so why go any further
actually sorry
and actually searching along starting
collecting basically if you want to
connect data if you want to find
connections those habits won't be that
good so let's flip things a bit
basically let's consider it on on
connecting data basically graphs and if
we go into this case what what is the
interesting part puffs
connections between two different nodes
that we don't exactly know the structure
for example and here we call start
hierarchical the data about genome and
so on and
there's a quite quite nice saying that
if your relations is the data go with
those databases Python there's a
basically division that you can have
graph as reporting and graph us
operations this is basically reporting
okay
I'm finishing sorry okay so basically
you are you are building here upon
multiple search engines and the way the
capabilities are mmm the capabilities
are made from the storage engines so we
can actually for choir in quick enough
finger pop we can have very very simple
very simple graph graph querying we can
have spark a debate with and so on we
can have solar elastic for clustering
distributed because we have large
amounts of data basically
transactionality built for reporting
neo4j computed in different database
open sourced data complete graph engine
it doesn't have it doesn't have any
schema so we can easily easily extend it
for querying we have cyber a really
awesome engine for korean graph data and
we have collection ality again for the
second time actually for clustering
masters life it's a basically relational
database for gravity bases and build for
on the introduction transactional
processing the problem actually
searching and sort of let's flip things
a bit actually for searching by a
hundred ninety degrees so what we go now
we have indexes but still listen and
those are not databases if someone is
saying that they are storing data in
seoul they can quite easily disappear so
basically those are two databases are
based on palm upon leucine so the same
search arjun and they have really minor
but quite important quite important
differences data xml in lesson yeah
querying miss leucine queries if anybody
used them quite obvious and basically
their work we have group by and this is
the distinction we can group by by
multiple servers in the cluster so
doesn't have it stuttering
quite complex with zookeeper but we can
increase the charts this a really minor
technical detail but if anyone we
you saw or a stick go into it reading
documentation because quite important
open source three open source anyone can
contribute elasticsearch data we only
have Jason because we are more hip and
we only wear Kareem leucine and of
course also an extension that basically
gives us some capabilities really minor
for clustering concert number of shares
and it's auto clustering it's really
really easy yeah auto balancing and the
cluster behaves more more or less like
like like the Redis cluster but the
open-source is only read-only you can
only contribute if you are the employee
of elastic company yeah I would read yes
we are finished but there are really a
lot of more databases what what are the
lessons the debates are like chili
peppers nak peppers if you don't know
which to choose really think multiple
times and check it because it can really
hurt next you can't have everything
basically there is no golden bullet
there is no no one solution but you can
have multiple databases and choose those
databases that are perfect for the
questions you will be answering less
than free there is no no SQL database
there are differences and the
differences are quite important read
upon them and basically yeah check them
that's all sorry for taking too long
[Applause]
we're running out of time
a little bit so I think we have time for
one questions and the other ones will be
adapter parting that I invite you
rolling I wasn't going to but um there's
a graph database in Python called the
Zod B what do you think of it I haven't
been using it to be honest basically I
would have to read them read into it but
but basically neo4j
took over the market they are way ahead
of everything there are most universal
decipher and if I would have to use
tinker popper or any this simple
low-level language for languages for
querying graph data you don't make any
sense because if you go to cypher you go
to a version of basic SQL and the power
of querying the power of being really
clean about this querying that's the
power that we should be using and not
going from node to node and then doing
all the operations by ourselves it
doesn't make any sense in my case that's
all
you